hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to answer questions
from one of my youtube viewers who is
starting the second business and started
his first business was 22 is now 30 the
first business failed and he's now
trying to start this new business wants
to follow a trend that I think is gonna
be hot and one of my advice and what to
do he's thinking about creating webinars
and web commercials for small business
owners and want my advice and what trend
to follow so my advice the most
important thing for any startup for any
entrepreneur is you have to follow what
you're passionate about so you'll be
great to follow a trend and you know
write that into the ground but it's got
to be something that you're really
excited about something where you can
add value where you're really passionate
where you can really help people out
don't just get into a trend because you
think it's hot you can make a lot of
money those are pretty short lived you
don't end up building a successful
company and I want to see you build a
type of company that you can be proud of
you can run for the rest of your life if
you want to something like they make you
really happy and it's not going to come
from just writing short term trends so
if you're thinking about the you know
making web videos for entrepreneurs it
could be a great model your best bet
start talking to customers if your
market is business owners go talk to
business owners see what they need see
how you can help them give them some
ideas it may be making these web
commercials that you're thinking about
or it could be something completely
different start talking your ideal
market see what they need and try to
help them solve that need the best way
to build the business is around paying
customers so go and start talking to
them don't pitch them on ideas go on and
ask them for their help awesome what
they're doing see if there's a way that
you can provide assistance to them
provide them value and more value can
bring them the moment you're going to be
able to make so that's my quick advice I
know this is your second business so
what I advise as well here is don't quit
now I don't know why you shut down the
first business it could be timing no
money issues whatever it was for this
one don't quit okay keep going at it
even if you're starting part time you
have to continue part time keep going at
it find ways to make it work you know
your initial idea almost never works it
always changes after you start talking
to customers are willing to pay you
build their own that keep them
going and don't give up with your new
business good luck if you guys like the
video please give it a thumbs up I
always appreciate seeing those come in
and if you have a question or if you
have anything else to add to this video
please leave a comment under the video I
love seeing those as well so thank you
and we'll see you on the next episode
you